hey guys this is comicdrake and a huge
super special shout out to rob thank you
very much for letting me have this video
on your channel hope you guys liked it I
think it's pretty awesome Booster Gold
I'm not Green Lantern
I'm Booster Gold this man is my favorite
superhero of all time and the greatest
hero you've never heard of seriously
that's actually the official tagline for
his comic it's kind of wonderful coming
from a poor home in the 25th century
thanks to his gambling father Michael
John Carter cheated away a full football
scholarship in order to help earn money
for a sickly mother's medical treatment
after he was exposed expelled from
college arrested and finally out of jail
the only job that Michael could land was
as a security guard for the metropolis
Space Museum at this illustrious Hall of
Heroes Michael steals a wealth of
gadgets on display from Legion of
super-heroes such as a legion flight
ring
Brainiac fives forcefield belt and a
time machine what's really odd about
this is that the Legion of super-heroes
was formed in the 30th century but
Michael stole their equipment from
museum in the 25th century which must
have gotten there from the legions 20th
century exploits of Superman
but that's another video for another day
with this stolen Legion gear and museum
security robot named Skeets Michael went
back in time to the 20th century where
he tried to capitalize on his knowledge
of the past as the hero gold star well
that is until he flub during his first
interview and accidentally said that his
name was Booster Gold and the name stuck
Booster Gold quickly became known as a
shameless self-promoter who was obsessed
with fortune and glory kind of sounds
like me this is cut a little out of hand
and irritated and plenty of its fellow
superheroes I mean heck later on when he
apparently dies his casket was covered
with corporate sponsor logos
self-promotion or not Booster Gold was a
successful hero and was even a founding
member of the Justice League
International most of which eventually
moved on to form the super buddies which
Booster Gold was also a part of it was
in the jail eye that Booster Gold met
his best friend Ted Kord the second Blue
Beetle
booster beetle are famous for their
hijinks and bromance to the point where
characters in the DC Universe speculate
that they might be gay then Ted kind of
dies oh this sends Booster Gold into a
downward spiral of depression that it
took a long time for him to get out of
now believe it or not Booster Gold is
taking part in plenty of big events in
the DC Universe for example did you know
that
doomsday first came to earth during the
death of Superman's story it was Booster
Gold who first ran into him and even
coined the name do you stay Superman I
catch a salmon says hey bro you look
plus during the 52 event big circle
gets wrapped up in an insane time loop
story involving himself time master rip
hunter in Super Nova who is an alternate
version of Booster Gold from the
not-too-distant future look we do not
have time to get into this right now so
after all of that Booster Gold gets
hired by rip hunter as a time master and
basically his job is to fix all the
holes in the DC Universe timestream
what's really awesome about this is that
Booster Gold ended up becoming a really
nice guy but he has to use his former
identity as a stump back as a cover up
for all these big time-traveling
adventures Booster Gold saves the entire
multiverse time and time again but never
gets credit for it that's ok though
because during all of this we get
treated to Booster Gold accidents firing
Sinestro to form the Sinestro Corps and
having a bunch of drinks with Jonah Hex
so Booster Gold did some more stuff but
then flashpoint happened and created the
new 52 but this somehow is worth things
get even more confusing the new Booster
Gold was short-lived in the lackluster
reboot of the just sleek international
book Booster leads a failed version of
the jli but at the end of the book an
order Booster Gold comes back in time
and warns himself but he needs to
prevent Wonder Woman and Superman from
getting together or else he would never
be born for some reason so the young
Booster Gold then just looks at a nearby
monitor sees Superman and Wonder Woman
just kissing each other and then BAM
boosters gone that's the last we've seen
of him save for a couple of appearances
every here and there so I guess we'll
need to wait and see what happens with
the upcoming convergence event outside
of the comics boosters appeared and just
like a limited an amazing portrayal on
Smallville Batman the briefing the bolo
to cameo in the Legion of super-heroes
cartoon DC Universe Online Lego Batman 3
and Syfy is actually trying to produce a
Booster Gold TV show but who knows if
it'll actually ever happen now if you're
looking to get into Booster Gold as a
character it's a little hard to do
without knowing at least a little bit of
the DC Universe since he's always
traveling through time but if you're
willing to risk it I'd recommend Booster
Gold 50 to pick up 52 and just League
International the original one not the
new 52 crap so this has been an older
video that I had over my channel but if
you liked it then please
head on over and check out my awesome
video on Bruce Wayne each into shield
horsey right here on Comics explain and
check out Rob's amazing video on the
origins of Gorilla Grodd